say Alice and Bob are on opposite sides
of the universe entanglement means that
somehow Alice measuring her particle
effects Bob's one even though it's a
world away immediately if that's the
case then the question for this video is
why can't they use quantum mechanics to
communicate instantly this video is very
much a sequel to a video I made about
entanglement and the EPR paradox
actually these videos are all a part of
a series on quantum mechanics so start
here if you're new
let's say Bob wants the answer to a yes
or no question that he's asked Alice but
she's waited until she's very far away
to think of the answer however luckily
they have an entangled pair of particles
between them he is a possibility Alice
tells Bob in advance but if he measures
his particle to be up the answer is yes
and down is no now all alice has to do
is non locally influence his particle to
be up say and then this communicated
faster in light but obviously that won't
work because no matter what she does her
own outcome is random and since Bob just
gets the opposite his outcome is just as
completely random as well so this scheme
doesn't work but a lot of you suggested
a much more devious plan I've been
saying for ages that you can tell the
difference between a state that's in a
superposition of two different
possibilities and one that's merely one
of these but you don't know which why
not use that if Alice measures the whole
state collapses and is not in a
superposition anymore then surely Bob
can do some sort of interference
experiment and if he sees no
interference
he knows that alice has done her
measurement otherwise she hasn't Alice
can communicate what she wants by
choosing whether to measure the her
particle or not then they could use this
scheme and communicate instantly across
the whole universe okay that sounds
great but obviously quantum mechanics
has a way around that too
I'll explain it but this is the punch
line with this entangled state you can
tell that they're in a superposition by
doing some measurement that shows
interference however that measurement is
a measurement where you have to interact
the particles in some way to do the
measurement and so you need both
particles in the same place if instead
you only do measurements on one of the
particles or even both of the particles
but not together there's no way for you
to tell the difference between the state
where they're in a superposition or when
they're not to see this let's look at
what happens when Bob does his
measurement in the case where Alice did
hers already or chose not to
in the case where Alice has measured his
particle really is up or down but he
doesn't know which now let's say Bob
does a measurement of the left or right
Ness of his particle we know that if we
did this to a particle that's up it will
go either left or right randomly and
same thing for a Down particle so even
though we don't know which it is up or
down we know it will go randomly left or
right and this is the no interference
results that we kind of talked about in
some previous videos this is kind of
what we expected but what happens in the
second case where the state is still in
a superposition this is a bit tricky
what you need to do is write the
particle state in particular Bob's
particle state in the left/right basis
try that and then see if you can figure
out what happens okay so here's the map
all I've done here is subbed in these
expressions then I'm grouping up the
left and the right options for Bob's
particle and then you can see that both
of these options have the same weight
and so they're both equally likely what
this means is if both measures his
particle for left or right Ness when
Alice hasn't measured the particle is
equally likely to go left or right which
is the same as if she had measured and
so you can't tell the difference hence
you can't communicate faster in life
okay but you might protest that I've
only shown that this plan for faster and
light communication is foiled for this
particular entangled state but what
about the other ones there are way way
way more possible entangled states than
justice I always use this example
because this state has the maximum
or entanglement but in fact most to
particle states are entangled
for example this state is entangled so
what would we need to do to show that
any entangled state is useless for
faster-than-light communication you need
to prove that no matter what Alice does
on her side that doesn't affect Bob's
measurement outcomes for example in
either case when Alice does or doesn't
choose to do a measurement Bob gets up
or down with the same probability either
way this can be proved more generally
but it's a little bit tough instead I'm
going to get you to do it for an example
that's a bit more challenging than the
one I did prove it for this state when
Alice measures up and down this and Bob
measures left or right now I'm going to
write out a detailed solution in the
description but ask me if you get
confused
so yes entanglement is useless for
faster and light communication but can
we try and use it for something else say
Alice and Bob have lots of entangled
particles between them if they measure
all of them then the outcomes are random
but they know what the other person's
outcome is so now they share a string of
random bits your second homework is to
look up and explain the usefulness of
something called a one-time pad also
comment on whether or not an encryption
based on a one-time pad coming from this
setup is secure or not if they know that
someone called Eve might be trying to
intercept the particles this is the
topic for the next video meanwhile
thanks for watching